i just got off a call with my colleagues
we are committed to staying here until
we have an agreement
an agreement that meets the needs of the
american people
house speaker nancy pelosi there putting
lawmakers on notice saying that they
will
stay put in the nation's capital until a
coronavirus relief bill is reached but
pelosi
is still not willing to budge on a 2.2
trillion dollar package
republicans have said that price tag is
a non-starter
so where does that leave us
congressional correspondent chad pergram
is live on capitol hill with more hey
chad good morning
good morning sandra well there's no new
talk scheduled nothing is really
changing here we are at status quo and
this is what is starting to worry
rank and file democrats especially those
who are moderates
those who flip districts from red to
blue in 2018
they want to get something done and they
are getting in the ear
of the democratic leadership including
max rose he's a freshman
from new york city we have allegiance to
our par to our country
we do not have allegiance to our party
leaders
house democratic caucus chairman hakeem
jeffrey says members
want to stay in washington
the overwhelming consensus amongst the
members
is that we stick around until we get
something done for the american people
but it won't work that way the house is
here for two weeks to deal with
unrelated bills house majority leader
steny hoyer
reiterated that members would be on 24
hour notice to return to washington
if there was a coronavirus agreement but
the last thing that leaders
will do is keep members waiting around
on capitol hill during a pandemic just
before the election
without a bill that makes members cranky
but they are
already cranky about no deal
pressures are mounting when we go home
and we talk to our constituents
and they are telling us heartbreaking
stories of having their electricity cut
off or
um not being able having to move out of
their home and
are standing in food lines those those
stories are heartbreaking
now it's unclear if anything could pass
the house of representatives right now
as we always say on capitol hill it's
about the math
it's about the math it's about the math
there is some chatter right now about
trying to do
individual bills but it's unclear if any
of those could pass
sandra i guess we're just going to have
to keep on watching where this goes next
chad bert i'm here every day
all right excellent you're on it thank
you chad